new in theaters this weekend ready or
not and don't let go well you see this
is your weekend ticket I can't believe
that in half an hour I will be a part of
the the Domus gaming dynasty Empire
Dominion we prefer Dominion yeah I
honestly can't wait to be a part of your
family there's just one more thing and
then you are officially part of the
family so at midnight get to play game
why it's just something we do when
someone new joins the family a game what
game I didn't seek are you really gonna
play that well the rules are simple you
can hide anywhere we then trying to find
you so there's no way for me to win
right and stay hidden don't wanna know
thank you good luck
the hell is this how old is this thing I
know you're in here sweetheart
you shot the maid does she look like
she's wearing a giant white wedding
dress ready or not ready or not is
already in theaters in this horror
suspense comedy Alex and grace have just
tied the knot as part of a family
tradition grace sits down with Alex's
family to play a little game sure why
not
grace chooses hide-and-seek she runs off
to hide and the game begins but she soon
learns the game is a lot more deadly
than she expected as Alex's family
trolls the house heavily armed looking
to kill her luckily her new boo decides
to help her out informs her this is all
part of some crazy ritual and that she
must survive the night had to play long
today I can get you faint they think
that the claim for sunrise there was
something very bad will happen to the
family if we don't find her and perform
the ritual we're all dead found her you
thought your family was weird I mean it
probably is that's just how it goes we
don't have to this movie is for you if
you want a pre Halloween horror movie
you like your horror with a little
comedy in it or if you're looking to
learn some new hiding places like behind
the bookshelf or a Hannah bad at this
game
[Music]
[Music]
No
so sorry jack
[Applause]
tell me this isn't happening I'll pray
for second chance to save even voices
once a day today yes
[Music]
new in theaters this weekend don't let
go when Jax nieces murdered he goes into
a downward spiral
one day he receives a call not only from
his deceased nieces phone number but
with her on the other side alive and
well was the date today
25th now with only the phone to
communicate
he needs to solve who killed her in
hopes of helping her prevent it in the
past yeah yeah that's it
this movie is for you and that suspense
flick sounds fun you like a good
Twilight Zone black hair type story or
you my god it's me from two weeks in the
past cats that is your weekend ticket
what will you see and check back next
week for more penny wise that dancing
clown
[Music]
[Music]